[Music]
what do you want from me
what do you want from me what are you
wondering
what do you know why are you scared
[Applause]
my
[Applause]
i need big shows big ideas hey i have a
big one
with click hello oh you know calloway
clay calloway is a recluse no one's seen
it for 15 years
i'll give you three weeks to get this
show up and running i won't let you down
sir better not or i'll throw you off the
roof
there's nothing holding me back
i have dreamt of performing in red shore
city since i was a little kid
there's nothing holding me back
this is my daughter portia she wants to
meet galloway big fan my sister is on
her way to meet him
right now
[Music]
your destination is on the right on the
right okay
if you could just give me some dance
lessons you will be saving my life
how do i know that you're not a weirdo
how do i know that you're legit when you
go crazy
and here she is the star of our show
she's afraid she'll never be able to
play the part maybe this is for the best
i'll write you another part
there he is clay calloway go away
don't you miss the music you just need
to play again
no i can't i haven't even heard one of
my songs
in over 15 years and for good reason
i have climbed the highest
mountains i have run
through the field it's okay
just sing what i'm looking for there's
only one way left to go
dream big that's what i always dreams
right
[Music]
there's always a choice just never have
the guts to make the right one
[Applause]
activating piggy power
[Music]
so
bye